the fact that matter is is that it's not
just the consumer
that's lying often and and saying like
oh yeah i'm coming with four people but
they have six or
i'll be there at eight and they show up
at seven instead because they really
wanted seven
it's also the restaurants that know that
that behavior is happening
about 15 of the time and suddenly
they're overbooking like you said
so the reason that you go to a popular
restaurant in new york city or san
francisco or chicago or l.a at 8 o'clock
on a saturday night you have reservation
they say go wait at the bar for 45
minutes because they lied to you
knowing that they wouldn't have that
table ready by eight o'clock and they
just said like but if we if we don't
the restaurant down the street's gonna
lie to them
and that eight o'clock reservation is
going to go then even though they won't
get seated till 8 45.
so i wanted to solve that that was the
initial thing now a whole bunch of other
stuff that's come
since then but in poker leveling uh yes
when people are like okay i know that
you think i'll be
here so therefore you're going to raise
so therefore i'm going to shove all in
so that you know this is the one out of
five times
that i actually did have it and i was
like that's right you're just leveling
people so the
literally the majority is leveling it's
the princess bride sicilian
this is yes so
it is very much that and it leads to
really really bad customer experiences
yeah it's bad hospitality and it's
inefficient for the restaurant on so
many levels it leads to food waste
it leads to extra costs and um that was
the initial problem that i was trying to
solve
and then we've gotten more sophisticated
at first we just started charging like
tickets like going to restaurants
entertainment you don't need to eat it
right 100
ever so i think it's the biggest
entertainment
industry in the world that is completely
miscategorized as as
non-entertainment and it's because
people are so
culturally sensitive to it because
it's part of our humanity we have to eat
every day as humans
and our cultures we were talking about
greece earlier
and our our ancestors like if i say
japan to you one of the first things
that people think of is japanese food
that's right a huge part of the culture
so as soon as you start having a
conversation about the hospitality
industry and any changes you want to
make
you go down this rabbit hole of very
emotional
very emotional very guarded about
trigger-wise yeah
it is yes and so um
there i was wanting to pre-charge for
reservation i mean
i made it into like business week and
newsweek and stuff just saying i'm
selling a ticket to a restaurant
yes and people lost their [ __ ] for no
good reason it's like who cares don't
come i don't care
yeah like you know it's like it's just
an experiment was sold out
and you did prefix so just saying like
listen you have to buy your tickets and
if you don't
show up for the next game okay
you didn't that was your choice yeah
yeah right the game's over you burn your
tickets
yes and that was my theory and it worked
um and then people went well but what
about a la carte restaurants in casual
places and i said
well what if we just charge a five
dollar deposit
and what's really crazy and this is true
for you
you've done very well with all of your
investments you put ten dollars down
that you can easily afford to lose you
will change your behavior
100 100 you now have skin in the game
you have skin in the game and also
you're like oh but i
you made a commitment it's way different
than holding a credit card number
and then me calling you after it said oh
yeah there's a 75
cancellation fee because you know showed
and it's a penalty then
but it's not a penalty if you choose to
put the 10 bucks in and make a small
down payment and the notion goes to
under three percent when you do that
and so we process millions of dollars
now every day of deposits
and that was a behavior that took 10
years to get restaurants to start doing
amazing and and what people also don't
know having grown up in the restaurant
business myself
is my dad ran his restaurant basically
on
almost a cash basis he had a bowl of
cash
that he had in a hidden spot he would
come home from the restaurant with all
the cash from the previous night throw
it in the bowl
then he would you know hand it out to
the different purveyors who was buying
from he'd hand them cash
it was just like he ran that out of his
little
dish in our yes
the three true box method and the third
true box put me through college
exactly basically is like you know
cash-based accounting
so if you're selling tickets you're
getting the money in advance now you
have the float
as the restaurant tour as opposed to you
being chased by your purveyors who gave
you 30 days to pay or two weeks to pay
this got to change the whole dynamic in
terms of
the funding of restaurants yeah and one
of the things that was
frustrating is that when covid hit there
was really well intentioned
famous chefs and restaurant owners going
on cnn every day saying
but you don't understand this is a
business that we pay for last week's
food costs with two weeks from now is
revenue
and i was like yes and that's the whole
problem
yes like there are people doing
businesses that do that
like that's a terrible way to do
business even even if you weren't
selling tickets let's just say you keep
operating the way you are accrue a cash
reserve
get rid of your net 90 credit call up
those purveyors and say hey what if i
pay you for the next two months ahead
yeah all of a sudden your food costs
aren't going to be running 34 anymore
they're gonna be running 24
right like this is these are business
principles
that i think the reason why
i i built talk the reason why i
i had some success in the restaurant
business
is because i ended up looking everything
is like an expiring option
right like everything was derivative to
me if there was a seat that was unfilled
at the end of the night i was like we
should have sold that for like half
price
we could have even sold that under food
cost
and had revenue that was incremental for
food that was going to be wasted
i want to welcome harry hurst you know
him as the co-ceo and co-founder of the
company pipe you've been on twitter over
the past year you've probably heard me
and my besties a number of which got
their beaks wet talking about all the
excitement around pipe and their
fundraising and the product they're
bringing
to market i thought i'd have harry come
on and explain it to y'all
harry welcome to the program thank you
jason the people who are
buying these contracts the annualized
contracts are looking to make 10
on their money and the person who's
selling that in advance believes they
could put that capital to work
that would help grow their revenues more
than 10 is that a way to look at it the
simple math if you take for example
95 cents on the dollar and you have a
hundred thousand dollar trade
can i take 95 000 today invest that
into say sales and marketing for growth
and generate
five thousand dollars in net new arr as
a result of investing that
if the answer is yes which i hope it is
for any growing company
your cash flow break even on the trade
if not cash flow positive on the trade
and you have the net new arr and you
know better mcleod index
not sure where it is today but anywhere
between 10 to 20 x
on that additional 5 000 can be seen as
your profit on the trade
so what we're trying to do at pipe is
turn people from having a borrower's
mentality where they would
traditionally go to say a lender and
borrow money to a trader's mentality
where they think of their recurring
revenue streams as an asset all right
thanks again
harry for coming on the pod and
explaining that with pipe.com there is
no debt
no loans and most importantly to me as
an angel investor no dilution
you sign up at pipe.com twist they'll
eliminate all your trading fees for one
full year what a generous offer pipe.com
twist so you can save up to tens of
thousands of dollars happy piping
everybody